for an art project a Pentagon a Pentagon
made of construction paper is cut into
five equal slices two of the slices are
removed right the remaining portion of
the Pentagon as a fraction so let's draw
ourselves a Pentagon a Pentagon is just
a five sided figure so it looks like
this it's also where the Department of
Defense is located a building that's
actually in the shape that's why they
call it it depend agon let me draw a
little nicer than that so it looks
something like this yeah my Pentagon
drawing skills need some work there you
go that's a pretty decent shot at a
Pentagon so that's the Pentagon made out
of construction paper notice says one
two three four five size that's why it's
called a Pentagon and it's cut into five
it's cut into five equal slices so we
could do that maybe that's that's the
center of the Pentagon here this is one
slice right there that is two slices
three slices four slices and then a
fifth line so you can imagine these are
all equal slices now they're saying two
of the slices are removed two of the
slices are removed so let's get rid of
two of these slices let's say we remove
that slice up there and let's say we
remove the slice right next to it right
over there and then they want us to
write the remaining portion of the
Pentagon as a fraction the remaining
portion of the Pentagon as a fraction so
what are the remaining slices well I
have this slice right there that slice
right over here and then this slice so
you have three slices remaining three
remaining out of a total possible of how
many how many slices are in the entire
Pentagon so if you look at the entire
Pentagon let me do it in this so the
entire Pentagon if you consider all of
the slices we have five slices so if you
consider the entire Pentagon is made up
of five total
Isis so it's three remaining out of five
total five total slices so you could say
you could say that three-fifths of the
Pentagon of the Pentagon of the Pentagon
remain or you could say two-fifths were
removed that's two of the five slices
were removed and then three are
remaining or three-fifths of the
Pentagon remain